This Goby fish in Hawaii can climb up 300
foot waterfalls. And physics students from
the University of Leicester have determined
that because of the doppler effect, hyperspace
travel would really look like...this....
Vsauce, Kevin here. This is Mind Blow.
A clothing store in Japan has a hanger system
that displays video of a model wearing the
clothes you remove from the rack. The hangers
have simple on/off switches depending on if
the article of clothing is hanging or is picked
up, and each have a unique ID that is tied
to a PC in the back which displays a photo
or video of the model wearing that piece of
clothing. It's kind of a digital take on mannequins,
but it's more of a novelty to try and get
online shoppers back into brick and mortar stores.
These LED ice cubes let you know when you've
had too much alcohol. Developed by an MIT
Media Lab researcher, the edible gelatin ice
cubes hold a coin cell battery, a microcontroller,
and a transceiver to track the number of sips
and total time drinking. They flash in sync
with ambient music, and change color to represent
the levels of intoxication.
Aspire Bariatrics has developed a system that
allows people to lose weight by emptying their
stomach with a valve after a meal. Aspiration
Therapy involves a tube in the stomach connected
to a Skin-Port that can be opened to empty
stomach contents before they pass into the
intestines where the calories are absorbed.
And then you just dump the stuff in the toilet...So,
yeah...
This is a newfound fossil of giant dolphin-shaped
predator considered to be the T-Rex of the
sea.
VELOCIRoACH is the second fastest legged robot,
clocking in at 3.2 meters per second. It moves
like a real cockroach with its legs
hitting the ground 15 times per second, and
the cardboard roach can move 26 times its
body length in only one second, and also can
carry four times its weight.
Diego San is a humanoid robot toddler that
combines advancements in robotics, neuroscience,
computer vision, developmental psychology
and machine learning. Developed at the University
of California, San Diego, it mimics the expressions
of a one-year-old child, and the plan is to
use it in studies on sensory-motor and social
development- basically, how babies learn to
control their bodies and interact with others.
The Power Loader Power Amplification Exoskeleton
Robot is being developed by Panasonic subsidiary,
Activelink. It's a full body exoskeleton designed
to carry over 220lbs, and they hope to use
a more compact version for use in the reconstruction
of the Fukushima Daiichi nuclear power plant.
Finally, photographer Katka Pruskova took
7,100 photos in 730 hours to create this timelapse
compilation of 22 flowers...
I'm gonna leave you with a Disco Clam: a type
of clam that produces its own light show.
And, as always, thanks for watching.